As an entrepreneur thinking
about how you take feedback and
how you figure out how you incorporate
that feedback into your business.
I think the most important thing is,
as an entrepreneur can
you take a step back?
Can you back away from maybe a narrow
problem you're trying to solve right
now, and really look at the big picture?
And can you take the feedback that's
coming in and apply it to the big
picture, without being so distracted
from what's happening in the weeds?
In particular for early stage companies,
if you look at the founders and
the co-founders, you know, they're
selling the product, they're building
the product, they're marketing it,
they're doing customer service.
And sometimes you can get so
focused on the detail, that when
somebody provides you feedback,
you don't understand how to take it,
unless you can really step back.
And that's a really important
attribute of a founder,
is can you step back from all of
the detail that you're working on and
incorporate the feedback
that's coming in.
And change directions if you need to.